Speaker 1: So the next piece of this seven
hours of missing call logs story is the obviously
unbelievable claim from Donald Trump that
he doesn't even know what burner phones are.
So as a reminder, yesterday we reported to
you White House records turned over to the
January six committee are missing about seven
and a half hours of logs.
This is a key seven and a half hours.
While the insurrection was going on, and one
of the sort of notable things that came out
of this was that Donald Trump denied having
any idea what a burner phone is.
In a statement Monday night, Trump said, I
have no idea what a burner phone is.
To the best of my knowledge, I have never
even heard the term.
This stunk to high heaven.
And when I told you this yesterday, the story
we didn't know about John Bolton's recent
comments, it was not plausible that Trump
didn't know the term burner phone, and it
was certainly not plausible that Trump doesn't
know about disposable phones.
If you wanted to be as charitable as possible
and give Trump the benefit of the doubt, which
I don't know why we would do at this point,
but let's say we did.
You might be able to argue Trump knows of
them as disposable phones, and he doesn't
know or remember the term burner phone, but
that wasn't even believable.
It really wasn't.
We now have new reporting from Donald Trump's
former national security adviser, who says
he specifically remembers Trump using the
term burner phones.
And of course, this is completely believable
and completely obvious, and it's what we suspected
right away.
CBS News reporting John Bolton, the former
national security adviser to Trump, told CBS
News he heard Trump use the phrase burner
phones in several discussions and that Trump
did know exactly what it meant.
In a response, Trump said he never heard the
phrase burner phone.
I have no idea what a burner phone is to the
best of my knowledge, I've never even heard
the term.
Bolton says he and Trump spoke about how people
have used burner phones to avoid having their
calls scrutinized.
I mean, you know, I know Trump's not the brightest.
But it did not pass the sniff test that Trump
didn't know what a burner phone was.
And this is increasingly reeking of Watergate.
I would encourage everybody in the audience
who is disturbed by this story, as you should
be, and you want to read a little bit more
about it.
There's a really good new piece in the New
Republic by Alex Shepard called Trump's missing
phone records have a familiar think of criminality.
And in that article, Alex Shepherd discusses
the analogies here to Watergate and mentions
that in terms of the amount of missing phone
data, it is more than 20 times longer in terms
of a gap in the records than what there was
in the Watergate tapes.
I don't know how many have recently reviewed
Watergate in all of its different elements,
but one of the things about Watergate was
a gap in tapes which ultimately scandalized
Richard Nixon and led to his resignation in
1974.
And the gap in the record with these Trump
phone calls is more than 20 times bigger than
the gap in that in the Watergate tapes.
The difference, of course, is that at the
time, Richard Nixon was president, and so
the entire scandal precipitated his resignation.
Trump is no longer president.
And of course, you and I would like to think
if people are reasonable, Republicans would
say, OK, even if I liked his tax plan, this
is just too much.
I can't vote for the guy in 2024.
Unfortunately, that's not the case.
And not only are there tens of millions of
voters at least still willing to vote for
Donald Trump still eager to vote for Donald
Trump in 2024, they become more emboldened
by these stories.
If you go and you look at right wing, YouTube,
right wing Twitter right wing talk shows like
Real America's Voice and Newsmax and all all
these different places, you see that they
are actually emboldened by these stories,
saying these are part of the witch hunt attacks
meant to take down Trump unfairly.
We renew our support for him as a result of
this investigation, which is really scary
stuff.
We'll have all these articles and more on
our Instagram.
You can follow us there, The David Pakman
Show.
We'll take a break.
We will talk about that.
Rick Scott 11.
Wacky plan.
After this short break